it is perfectly acceptable to abandon
your wife and children on a weekend
to do a four-hour podcast with a couple
of dudes while enjoying cigars and
whiskey of course it is that we wouldn't
have done it who would suggest otherwise
you know when I think about the
different kinds of love you get to drive
I get to drink yeah there are different
kinds of love and today we all we talk
about is romantic love or perhaps then
in its fulfillment the love between
spouses and love what about philia
what about friendship proper friendship
yeah huh yeah so why are you yelling at
me about going and having three or four
coca-colas with the boys over at
George's place for four hours multiple
cigars when we're talking about philia
this is a very very high form of
friendship